as part of big think mentor which is a
big things lifelong learning channel on
YouTube I'm Jason gots and we're very
very happy today to be joined by Maria
konnikova author of mastermind how to
think like Sherlock Holmes in her
workshop on big think mentor she teaches
thinking skills from the master sleuth
including observation deduction and
imaginative problem-solving among others
and we're here as a follow-up to that
workshop with Sid Burgess who's a member
of big Fink mentors learning community
welcome Maria were delighted that you're
here for this I've never done a Google
Plus hangout before so and this is our
first ever so bear with us if there's
background noise or any other technical
interruptions or you know suddenly the
Google Plus animation of a mustache or
so I think what we'll do we'll start
with you know essentially this is a
follow-on to Maria's workshop on mentor
which is called how to think like
Sherlock Holmes you can get there by
going to youtube.com slash user slash
big think mentor and we're asking
follow-up questions I have some
questions we've got other questions from
members of mentors community and we'll
start with Sid and Sid if you'd like to
introduce yourself you know say a couple
of words about what brought you to
mentor or what you know what what you're
what you're up to
and then and then go ahead and ask Maria
your questions yeah I saw I just I think
Sid Burgess I think I'm just kind of
addicted to the notion of trying to hone
personal skills to try to you know
improve your life and day to day just I
enjoy the topic in general so I've been
a big fan of the channel and even before
you guys went to the big think mentor so
I'm really kind of excited to be a part
of this yeah I had a question just to
kind of kick things off I really was
curious what some of the mentors was
wanting to get out of this whole
experience themselves we sort of are
used to kind of receiving this feedback
or receiving this these
good ideas but part of a part of the
part of the brilliance of this whole
kind of community is is that everybody's
kind of is getting something out of it
too as well so I'm just kind of curious
Murray what are you looking to get out
of big think mentor well I'm looking to
get out of it that's a wonderful
question questions just like the one
that you asked so when you really have
people who interact with you and who
asking you questions you look at things
in a different way and it makes you
think about topics that you wouldn't
think about otherwise which i think is
really important so when I whenever I
answer questions from readers whenever I
get talks and answer questions from the
audience there's you know there are
always questions that repeat but there's
always something new and I say huh
that's really interesting and then I
start thinking about it and it lets me
develop my ideas it's kind of like the
Holmes Watson relationship actually to
uh gonna bring it back to that I think
that Watson really improves Holmes's
linking and Holmes becomes much better
throughout the stories the more he
interacts with Watson because Watson
asks provocative questions he always
forces moments to stop and think why
he's doing what he's doing and that kind
of back-and-forth is incredibly
important to keep your thinking sharp to
keep yourself stimulated I don't think
that anyone should ever really work in a
back to it even though writing is often
a very solitary profession but that
interaction I think it's incredibly
important great Jason you owe me ask my
second question absolutely go grinning
alright so the second one is it's one of
them actually had kind of mulling around
my mind for a while as this notion of
being too distracted and multitasking
and you brought it up in one of your
videos so I really wanted to ask you
specifically I enjoy going with my
favorite place in the world it really
doesn't matter which one it is is the
coffee shop its enjoys sitting in the
coffee shop just kind of watching the
world go by and people watching as we
like to say but almost more than that -
I just enjoy kind of just almost in a
sense of meditation and just taking in
all the sights and sounds of whatever
city that I'm in and trying to process
them
simultaneously so I wanted to just ask
you how how would you how would you
describe maybe in a way that would help
help improve that that mental exercise
in the way that differentiates that from
kind of the multitasking or the
endorphin driven kind of electronic
distraction that we hear a lot about it
can be cut maybe differentiate the two a
little bit and maybe how we can focus it
on on the better one sure so what you
like to do is definitely not
multitasking
that's kind of you know tasking at its
best because you're doing something very
specific you're kind of watching or
letting your senses take everything in
so I think the the myth about
multitasking is that you you can't be
looking at multiple things at once and
have that not be multitasking you can't
be doing multiple activities at once so
your brain can't be thinking okay I want
to do this but also I want to do this oh
I'm watching these people but also I'm
focused on what I'm going to order at
the coffee shop what I'm going to have
for lunch what I'm going to do after I
leave the coffee shop what else I have
planned for the city if you were
thinking all of these things at the same
time then you'd be multitasking but if
you're kind of in the moment and just
soaking everything in using all of your
senses that's really sensory you know
taking in the moment in a very mindful
fashion which is the purpose of
mindfulness so I think those are two
very very different experiences and in
order to really I think to get a lot of
out of what you do and get more out of
that type of people-watching which by
the way I think is really interesting
and fascinating and helps you just
develop as a as a person and develop
your thinking and develop your powers of
observation is really realize that
that's exactly what you're doing and do
your best to avoid distracting thoughts
so if you see someone and that you know
puts your mind along the lines of oh hey
that person reminds me of my friend X
and suddenly you're thinking elfin X in
your mind is going on a tangent realize
that that's happening stop yourself and
come back to just observing and taking
everything in I think that's how you can
make the
most thanks okay great um I have other
questions from other mentor members who
would have liked to have been with us
today but could not for technical
reasons so we've got Matthew J Clarke is
asking what are the current theories
about why task switching causes fatigue
and that's that's how he worded the
question and unfortunately folks aren't
here to do follow-up but of course so we
know that attention is an incredibly
finite resource so there's really only
so much of it to go around and we can
train our attention so that we become
better but we'll never be able to make
it infinite and so one of the things
that task switching does is use up
mental energy so you need resources to
switch your focus from one thing to
another and the theory is actually is
very simple the more your mind is doing
the more resources it needs and so every
time you switch your attention you're
actually switching circuits you're
switching your focus you're switching
control mechanisms behind it and that
expense energy literally you can
replenish it by having glucose or other
other things that actually boost your
energy levels so it's a very very
literal thing that happens your brain is
actually getting tired you're actually
losing resources and you're actually
becoming less able to do other things
because you use those resources for the
task switching now you no longer have
them to pay attention to the tasks that
you're doing there's a lot of really
interesting work that shows that people
who multitask frequently are less
efficient at task switching because
they're always they don't know how to
take those resources and really use them
to their full potential which i think is
really fascinating because it ends up
that heavy multitaskers become worse at
the very thing that they should be very
good at right I've read some of that
research and yeah it's fascinating
because you know the sort of plugged in
millennial folks who you would think
would be the best at
at this actually the more they multitask
it seems the worse again hmm you know
they become worse at being able to
filter out distractions and that's a
good thing if you want to make sure that
you're paying attention to everything
but you also get off tasks very very
frequently and very easily which is not
a good thing so not being able to filter
out distractions can make you worse at
task switching to the tasks you actually
want to be switching to if that makes
sense yeah maybe like oh hey there was
this distraction maybe I'll do that
instead so in this regard do you think
that sort of we're all doomed given the
you know technological uh you know Moke
the sort of multitasking world that
folks are growing up in now or are there
things people can do you know to to
counteract that I mean you know there's
concerns about people being addicted
sure no I don't think we're all doomed
at all I think that technology is
wonderful and that we just need to be
aware of how much you go pull it exerts
on us and how difficult that can be to
avoid so what I would say is we need to
learn to train our attention because as
with anything attention is like a muscle
it's in the knowledge that you hear all
over and over in psychology self control
like a muscle
you know everything basically you can
say hey it's like a muscle because it's
an analogy that works incredibly well so
if you train it it gets stronger it gets
better you are able to well weights you
can you have more endurance and
similarly with attention the more you
train yourself to you need tasks and to
only pay attention to one thing at a
time the longer and longer and longer
you're able to maintain your focus so
what's happening when people say that
they can't pay attention is that they
haven't trained their attention they've
forgotten what it is to have a
single-minded focus and because they
haven't trained it their attention
actually has gotten worse so I think
that people you know when they say they
can't pay attention they really can't it
doesn't just happen overnight and so
what we can do is try to monitor
ourselves and really learn to do one
thing at it
for me that's there's been a lot that
I've had to do to actually maximize my
own potential when I was writing
mastermind I realized how internet
addicted I was and I actually needed to
install freedom which is an Internet
blocking software on my computer so that
I wouldn't go online and it was really
hard for me but eventually I was able to
stay off mine for four or five hours at
a time and I turned my phone off because
otherwise I'd be too tempted to check my
internet on the iPhone because
unfortunately freedom doesn't yet block
all of your devices and now I don't
really need it because I I know I do it
and I've already trained myself not to
it's still nice once in a while I think
we all need to give ourselves mental
breaks and realize that the Internet is
wonderful but sometimes it's good to
just focus and not like those need no
notifications those Twitter
notifications all of those things that
can just suck our attention
no not let them interfere gotcha and
speaking of attention for our viewers
the noise that sounds like the ocean is
most likely some you know Maria lives in
a fairly noisy neighborhood nothing we
can really do about that okay let me
continue with people's questions because
I could I could do follow-ups here all
day Matthew also asks how can you
habituate an input from one sense so
that it does not interfere with the
attention you give to another sense for
example reading body language while
having a conversation well I think that
there are actually two different issues
here habituation is a very specific term
when it comes to psychology and you
don't do it it just happens it's
something that's incredibly incredibly
natural so as soon as that as there's a
stimulus that you're hearing often you
do become habituated to it so for
instance one of my favorite examples
comes from my personal experience
my freshman year of college I had a huge
Church right outside my windows and it
the bells would ring and on weekends
adults would ring and I was a college
freshman I wanted to sleep um and at
first they'd always wake me up and I got
to the point where I didn't even hear
them I didn't realize that was for um
we're ringing and it's not that I made a
conscious effort to habituate your brain
learns to kind of block out the noises
that it's ears all the time and the same
can be true of vision so that's why you
often you know if he tells if you asked
me you know what do I pass on my way to
work every day I might not be able to
answer I'm here think oh I know exactly
what I passed but because I do it every
day I don't pay attention to it because
I've become habituated to all those
sites and I may not it may not even
notice that store has closed or a new
store has opened and extent unless
something draws my attention to it and
I'm out of my situation State so it just
happens and what we can do is actually
not habituated and try to if we don't
want to the active part is not
habituation but withstanding habituation
if that makes sense
okay um so one other question from
another mentor member joeandfrannie
Noel asks Watson is really helpful to
Holmes do you have tools or ideas for
you know solutions to create our own
imaginary Watson or other ways to get a
similar benefit without having a Watson
you don't have one yeah that's uh it's
interesting and it stopped short of
saying have imaginary people
conversation in your heads just because
that you could take that a little bit
too far but you can learn to kind of
argue with yourself and to always that's
actually how I get a lot of my thinking
done you know I I say okay this is what
I think well what's the counter-argument
to that or why do I think that way so
force yourself almost to be in a debater
mindset always it doesn't just
more critical of yourself and makes a
critical of all of the information that
you're taking in of everything that
you're reading and everything that
you're watching of all the constant news
and other inputs that you get every day
if you just don't take it in as commit
as it give him and say oh that makes
sense
rather always play devil's advocate and
say wait that doesn't make sense because
you know in a large way that's exactly
what Watson does and the other good
thing to do is get yourself a lot
sun-sin so get yourself someone you know
with whom you can discuss things someone
who listens to you
it's really good to talk things through
and I think you often find that button
you see gaps in logic when you say
something out loud that before you you
never really voiced and so one of the
ways that can do that is if you think
that you know what you're doing actually
pretend that you need to explain it to
someone else and explain it
yeah out loud or you can even write it
out so writing is it is a good exercise
to what you can say hey did I really
understand this because writing shows
gaps in logic very very strongly so if I
write something and I'm like wait that
was a bit of sense in my head but on the
page it suddenly doesn't make sense I
have to try to figure out why that's the
case and anyone can do that
anyone else you don't need to talk to
yourself you don't need to imagine
conversations all you have to do is
write out your argument as if you were
explaining it to someone else or write
out your thinking as if you were
explaining it to someone else that's
interesting yeah that's why it can be
helpful to keep it a journal I know then
I've experienced that in writing a
journal that you start writing you know
your thoughts about things and you're
surprised to like your perspective on
them is completely different from what
you might have thought it was in your
head so so I have a couple of questions
of my own and maybe in the interest of
time I'll ask just one of them and then
see if Sid has a follow-up and and then
we'll close out I'm looking over here at
another computer that's why I'm not
looking
everyone um many of the points you made
by gas geisha yes very well
many of the points you make in the
workshop add up to the fact that we
can't trust our own common sense that
and end in your book of course
mastermind our minds make up stories
they're biased to pay attention to some
things and ignore others and in order to
solve problems more effectively we need
to examine our assumption assumptions
rigorously and consider the data in ways
that don't necessarily come naturally to
us which is very counterintuitive in
some ways to at least the culture I grew
up in American culture of you know trust
yourself you know and Trust what sort of
your common sense in a sense not only is
this practically hard as we're biased to
trust ourselves it might also be
emotionally hard in that many of us
construct our identities and sense of
self-worth security etc around self
trust surround trust in our own sort of
common sense what are your thoughts
about how to manage like if somebody is
training themselves to be more skeptical
more critical of their own thinking how
to manage that transition motional e'en
otherwise I think that's a really
interesting question and I think that
the way the way that I view it is it's
not don't trust yourself it's don't
trust yourself when you have no reason
to do so when you have no experience in
something so experts can trust all of
their instincts and their common sense
in their areas of expertise and the
problem comes when non experts have a
quote unquote common sense opinion that
really is just coming out of nowhere and
we do that all the time there areas
where were expert but then we do the
exact same thing in areas where we're
not really expert so if you think for
instance I see this person and he's
acting shifted to me my common sense is
he's doing something wrong you shouldn't
distress that that common sense because
you're an expert in looking at people
and in reading body language you've done
that your entire life so something as
simple as that you actually are an
expert
and you should listen to yourself even
if you're not really sure why you think
something you might be picking up on
cues
the trick is ask yourself why do I think
this person is acting suspicious am I
actually reading body language or am i
using non expertise am i putting someone
else am i putting someone else in this
situation and this person just reminds
me of someone I don't like so now I
think they're shifting so you have to
it's not about not trusting yourself per
se it's about examining the reasons for
your assumptions and always saying okay
am i actually making this judgment based
on some sort of expertise or am I like
one of those people who makes a decision
about whether or not I would hire
someone in the first thirty seconds of
an interview just because I liked them
or didn't like them in which case
there's no expertise there you you don't
know anything about the person so I
think it depends on the judgment and it
depends on what you're using to get
there if that makes sense yeah that's a
fun make sense okay so I think yeah I'll
ask one more question and then we'll and
then we'll turn it over to sit this is
about the value of creativity and
imagination how well two psychologists
at this point understand creativity I
imagine it's not something it's not a
subject that gets you know heavy
research dollars thrown at it have their
insights yet yielded anything that you
would think of as a sort of practical
useful approach to teaching or enhancing
people's creativity beyond letting your
mind do its thing you know daydreaming a
etc yeah I think that we're starting to
understand creativity but it's a really
really hard thing to study because there
are many different types of creativity
there are many manifestations of
creativity it's not like an overarching
entity you are or you are not creative
you can be creative in different ways
and they're different ways of having
creative insights so psychologists
started a little bit
limited in that they have to study
things in a laboratory and so they have
to have an artificial paradigm and so
they try to figure out well okay how can
i approximate creativity um so that's
why you get a lot of these studies that
look at the Eureka moment the aha moment
where you are able to put things
together in a new way that's one way
that you can study creativity but it's
and we're learning a lot about that
we're learning how people can become
better at that but once again that's a
very very specific type of creative
thinking and being good at those you
reek of problems or is not the same
thing as being more creative overall
what we do know that's something that
everyone can do is that for whatever
reason being in nature helps people
become better at problem solving so
being surrounded by trees by water and
it's it's those types of things for
whatever reason maybe people that aren't
able to to have insights into think of
imaginative solutions so it's not just
you niihka moments it's also you know
you became better eyebrow brainstorming
the quality of your brainstorm ideas
becomes deeper and the more that we
actually the more we like to pay
attention the more we focus on things
that's also the other and a part of the
puzzle there's business this focused
part of creativity people always say
that it's taking the breaks and those
breaks are incredibly important but you
have to realize that for homes and for
any other creative person there's also a
lot of hard work that comes before and
you can't distract yourself while you're
doing that so Holmes does have these
bouts of intense thinking and
concentration versus really mulling over
the problem before he takes his break he
takes his break she already has a lot of
that worked through and whenever you
hear of you know people like Wong cafe
or anyone else who's often used as an
example of breakthrough creativity and
they spent weeks hours you know years
sometimes mulling over problems and so
then the insight comes in a second
but very different parts to that so I
think we can train our concentration we
can take more walks in natural habitats
and those are the things we definitely
know can help it's a field that's that's
getting more and more attention I think
people would really love to know how to
become more creative and the good news
is that you can be you can become more
creative and I think that everyone has a
certain degree of creativity in them
it's not the type of thing you know you
can't say oh I'm not a creative person I
don't think not creatively exist
great um so listen up all you people who
like me who think of yourselves as
creative and live in big cities time to
get out into the park and one of the
most interesting points I think you know
Maria that you make in your book
mastermind and and in the big thing
mentor workshop how to think like
Sherlock Holmes is this fact that you're
this is that Sherlock Holmes is a
creative problem solver that he does
take information and recombine it in
imaginative ways you know we tend to
associate creativity falsely with the
arts only often and and and think of
science and you know being a detective
as somehow more kind of rational linear
and a little move not creative and I
think that's a really really important
point that you make okay so with that
said Sid did you have any follow-up
questions you'd like to ask before we
before we wind this up I have a simple
one maybe just be good by close I kind
of curious did Maria did you ever have
or what was an aha moment for you in
reading any of the home stories what was
the aha moment or was there a particular
aha moment for you reading in the
stories we just you know or just kind of
hit you and like oh that makes perfect
sense the way he was approaching a
problem well I definitely had an aha
moment when I realized that I wanted to
write about Holmes and I started me
reading all the stories and I was it was
mother
meeting all of them in very close
succession very very closely to no
underlining highlighting writing notes
in the margins kind of doing this very
close reading and my aha moment was that
Sherlock Holmes really is a different
type of thinker from the thinker that I
remembered from childhood and the devera
that he's often portrayed as being
because he's so imaginative and creative
and warm and you have not a cold machine
at all and it was very to me it was one
of those huh why do people always think
of him as this logical otamatone as as a
computer when he's anything but when all
the things that make him Sherlock Holmes
are things that a computer can't
accomplish all right and that to me was
or feels exactly exactly yeah it was
really eye-opening because even from my
childhood from reading the stories I
didn't remember that I instead had that
stereotype books he's this computer is
just this perfectly logical person he's
anything but it yeah okay great um so I
I want to thank everyone out there in
the live audience for joining us today
um and Sid Burgess from our big think
mentor community and special thanks to
Maria konnikova for for being with us
you've you've been watching our big
think mentor hangout with Maria
konnikova author of mastermind how to
think like Sherlock Holmes visit
youtube.com slash user slash big think
mentor to take Maria's workshop on
thinking skills from the master
detective and learn life skills for
personal and professional growth
I'm Jason gots an editor with big Fink
and thanks everyone for joining us today
Sid and Maria thank you thank you thanks
for having us